نقل موقع بلومبيرج عن رئيس الشركه التي
تزود اسرائيل بالطائرات المسيره قوله ان
الحرب مع حماس تعتبر بمثابه دعوه للجيوش
للانتباه وتطوير امكاناتها الفتاكه وقال
الموقع ان ما وصفها بطائرات حماس الرخيصه
تفوقت على الجيش الاسرائيلي عالي التقنيه
كما اعتبر الموقع ان استخدام الطائرات
المسيره التجاريه المجهزه
بالقنابل كشف ثغرات في الدفاعات
الاسرائيليه ينضم الينا من رام الله
الخبير والمحلل العسكري واصف عريقات سيد
واصف اذا السلاح الرخيص الذي تعتمده
المقاومه يتفوق على السلاح عالي التقنيه
الذي لدى اسرائيل بحسب موقع بلومبرج ما
قولكم في
ذلك يعني بالتاكيد دائما وابدا نقول ليس
المهم السلاح بقدر ما من يحمله ومن
يستخدمه حينما يستخدم السلاح من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين بارادتهم بشجاعتهم بمعركه
العقول
والادم بمهارات الميدان التي يتدربون
عليها انا بتقديري هذا يصبح السلاح مهما
كان سعره يصبح فعال وكما لاحظنا في السلاح
في القواذف قواذف
الياسين
وهي مستنسخه عن الارب جيهات اربجيهات التي
تصنع في المصانع الدوليه في الاتحاد
السوفيتي سابقا في روسيا الان
وتكلف مبالغ عاليه جدا ولكن في في قطاع
غزه هي لا تكلف كثيرا
فبالتالي ليس مهم السلاح وثمن السلاح بقدر
من يستخدم هذا السلاح و نلاحظ ايضا ان
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين بالمتفجرات البسيطه
استطاعوا ان ي يدمروا دبابات من نوع
ميركافا التي تكلف م ملايين الدولارات
وكذلك الاليات المجنزره والجرافات وهذا ما
دلت عليه الصور ربما التي بثتها كتائب
القسام لا سما الصور التي بثت بالامس
وبينت اعطاب كبيره في اليات جيش الاحتلال
وفي قدره المقاومه
على القيام بعمليات قريبه جدا من جنود
الاحتلال ما الدلالات والرسائل التي
تضمنتها باعتقادك هذه
المشاهد يعني هذا هذا يؤكد بان اول شيء
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وبعد 75 يوم من
الحصار بالطائرات وبالمدفع من البر ومن
البحر و1 الف جندي اسرائيلي يحاولون
التمدد والتوغل داخل قطاع
غزه هذا يعني ان هناك اعجاز عسكري حقيقه
هذا المقاوم الفلسطيني الذي
يستطيع ان ينصب كمائن للدبابات وجنود
الاسرائيليين ويشتبك معهم على مسافه صفر
ويصيب اهدافه
بالكورن ويصور بفيلم فيديو وبصوته يكبر
ويشرح ويشرح كيف تجري العمليه العسكريه
هذا انا بتقديري رساله ل لوزير الحرب جلنت
لرئيس هيئه اركان هالفي لاصحاب القرار
خاصه العسكريين الذين يخططون ل
لقتل المدنيين الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه
وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل على ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يوجد له اي كفاءه ميدانيه
مقابل المقاومين الفلسطينيين المقاومه
الفلسطيني استطاع ان يهزم هذا الجيش
الاسرائيلي رغم كل تدريباته ورغم كل
مناوراته ورغم كل ما يمتلكه من اسلحه
حديثه وخاصه من الدبابات ومن الطائرات ومن
المدفعيه فاذا ما تقابل هذا الجندي
الاسرائيلي مع المقاوم الفلسطيني بعيدا عن
اسلحه الاسناد وهو كما يجري الان بالحارات
حينما
يحاول الجنود الاسرائيليين التوغل في داخل
بعض الشوارع وفي داخل الازقه احيانا لجمع
معلومات او ربما لاستهداف بعض الاشخاص
نجدهم يقتلون يقتلون ولا يستطيعون مواجهه
المقاتل سيد واصف الجيش الاسرائيلي ورغم
ضغوط عليه ب ان ينتقل الى مرح ح اخرى من
هذه الحرب يختلف
شكلها يصر المسؤولون الاسرائيليون على ان
هذه الحرب يجب ان تطول لاسابيع واشهر حتى
تحقق اهدافها
باعتقادك على ماذا يراهن الجيش الاسرائيلي
في تحقيق
الاهداف يعني هو بالتاكيد يراهن على
استنزاف المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لذخائر
لهم 75 يوم تحت الضرب يعني برا وبحرا وجوا
لا يوجد من يبدلهم يعني اوضاعهم صعبه صحيح
ولكن هؤلاء المقاومين يقاتلون باراده
بشجاعه ويعرفون تماما ان مهمتهم الاساسيه
بغض النظر عن كل الظروف الصعبه التي يمرون
فيها ان ان لديهم قدره على الصبر وعلى
مواجهه الاحتلال رغم ان هناك 19500 شهيد
فلسطيني هناك 60,000 جريح ف بالتالي هذه
كلها تحاول اسرائيل من خلال الضغط على
المدنيين
وقتل اكبر عدد ممكن من المدنيين ومحاوله
تهجيرهم وتجويعهم وتعطيش ان تضغط على
المقاومين الفلسطينيين ولكن انا بتقديري
من من اعد لخطه عمليه طوفان الاقصى يوم
710 اعد كامل الاحتمالات
وربما حسب حساب ردود الفعل الاسرائيلي وان
المعركه ستطول شكرا اشكرك جزيل الشكر واصف
عريقات الخبير والمح العسكري ضيفنا من رام
الله